(chants d'oiseaux)
- Un arrêt, un moment
de recueillement;
le temps pour Justin Trudeau de
se souvenir d'un sombre chapitre
de l'histoire du Cambodge.
On évalue que le génocide
mené par les Khmers rouges
a fait deux millions de morts
dans les années 70.
Dans cette ancienne prison,
des milliers de personnes on
été affamées, torturées, tuées.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier ministre du Canada
- Nous avons tous
l'tititition de se souvenir...
pour ne jamais voir répéter
nulle part ailleurs.
- Devoir de mémoire pour un
premier ministre confronté aux
grands défis du monde actuel.
Au très attendu Sommet du G20,
Justin Trudeau et ses alliés
devront trouver comment
se dresser devant de grands
régimes autoritaires,
comme la Chine et la Russie.
Le premier ministre mise
sur la fermeté pour dénoncer
la guerre en Ukraine.
- C'est une guerre qui fait
des ravages horribles et qui
a des répercussions partout
dans le monde. Poutine a créé
une crise énergétique,
de l'insécurité alimentaire.
- Le Canada annoncera un nouveau
plan d'aide à l'Ukraine pendant
le G20 et promet de tout faire
pour isoler la Russie.
Au sommet, Justin Trudeau
a l'intention d'ignorer
le ministre des Affaires
étrangères russe.
- En général, j'ai p
particulièrement intérêt
à parler directement à Lavrov.
- Mais concernant la Chine,
il reste plus va
Va-t-il aborder avec Xi Jinping
l'ingérence chinoise dans les
élections canadiennes de 2019?
Il ne s'en f f f f formellement
à parler au leader chinois.
- Comme toujours, je vais
souligner la question
deumumumumumumains,
des principes de défense
de nos institutions avec
tous les leaders avec quieseses.
- Mais lundi, les yeux du monde
seront tournés vers les
présidents chinois et américaine
depuis que Joe Biden est
à la Maison-Blanche.
En plein regain de tensions
autour de l'autonomie de Taïwan,
les deux rivaux se mesurent
et s'évaluent. Joe Biden cherche
à identifier les lignes à ne pas
franchir entre les deux pays.
Le Groupe des 20 paraît
plus divisé que jamais.
Deux blocs s'affronten
d'un côté, les pays occidentaux,
bien décidés à isoler Moscou;
et de l'autre, ceux qui
ont refusé de condamner
l'invasion russe en Ukraine.
Un tel clivage
peu de place aux compromis et
réduit les espoirs d'en arriver
à des avancées concrètes
à l'issue du G20.
Ici Louis Blouin,
Radio-Canada,
Phnom Penh, au Cambodge